si sumas todos los puntos de las fichas
de dominó hay 63 puntos aunque eri o sea
que si tomamos todas estas fichas de
dominio y sumamos todos estos puntos
obtenemos 63 y después nos dicen que
esos 63 puntos son 42 puntos más que el
número total de puntos en un dado de
seis lados ok si tuviéramos por aquí un
dado que se ve más o menos así que
digamos que aquí tiene un punto y por
aquí tiene tres puntos
y dos puntos y nos ponemos a contar
todos los puntitos en ese dado en las
caras que si podemos ver y en las caras
que están detrás que no estamos viendo
en este momento esa suma es el número
total de puntos en un dado de seis lados
que es justo lo que queremos averiguar
aunque y lo que nos están diciendo es
que el total de puntos en estas fichas
de dominó la suma de todos estos puntos
63 es 42 puntos más que el número total
de puntos en este dado bueno vamos a
borrar el dado
averigüemos cuántos puntos hay en un
dado de seis lados y bueno siempre que
estemos resolviendo un problema con
palabras es una muy buena idea pensar en
qué es lo que nos están pidiendo aquí
nos están pidiendo cuántos puntos hay en
un dado de seis lados y una muy buena
pregunta es si esa cantidad que nos
están pidiendo va a ser más grande o más
chica que la cantidad que nos están
dando que en este ejercicio son los 63
puntos de estas fichas de dominó ahora
es muy probable que tú hayas visto este
ejercicio rápidamente y hayas dicho ok
aquí nos están diciendo 42 puntos más
entonces debemos de sumar pero no uno no
puede hacer esto en estos problemas
aunque uno no debe simplemente buscar a
ver si se encuentra con la palabra menos
o más y en base a eso
o sumar ok porque no siempre que aparece
la palabra más tenemos que sumar y no
siempre que aparece la palabra menos
tenemos que restar uno tiene que
entender muy bien qué es lo que está
pasando en el problema y en base a eso
decidir si sumas o restas en este
problema nos dicen que el número total
de puntitos en estas fichas de dominó es
63 y que esa cantidad de puntitos
son 42 puntos más que el número de
puntos en un dado de seis lados y lo que
queremos saber es cuántos puntos hay en
un dado de seis lados pero bueno otra
forma de pensar en eso es tomar esta
cantidad el número de puntos en un dado
de seis lados y llamarle por ejemplo
signo de interrogación y lo que nos
dicen es que si tomamos esta cantidad
si tuviéramos 42 puntos más entonces
tendríamos la misma cantidad de puntitos
que en estas fichas de dominó las cuales
tienen 63 puntitos ok si empezáramos con
la cantidad de puntos en un grado de 6
lados y agregaremos 42 puntos más
entonces tendríamos 63 63 el número de
puntos en un dado de 6 lados más 42 es
igual a 63 o dicho de otra manera 63 son
42 puntos más que el número de puntos en
un dado de seis lados
ok siempre hay que pensar en qué es lo
que nos están diciendo lo bueno es que
ya podemos ponernos a averiguar cuánto
vale este signo de interrogación porque
si tenemos que el signo de interrogación
más 42 es igual a 63
eso significa que el signo de
interrogación es igual a 63 63 menos 42
menos 42 y esta resta cuánto es pues lo
podemos averiguar por aquí 63 son seis
decenas y tres unidades y le estamos
restando 42 y 42 son cuatro decenas y
dos unidades y estamos restando y cuando
terminemos de hacer esta resta vamos a
obtener el número de puntos que hay en
un dado de seis lados entonces pues
vamos a empezar por las unidades tenemos
tres unidades menos dos unidades tres
menos dos es uno y luego seis decenas
menos cuatro decenas y seis menos cuatro
son dos o sea que tenemos 21 dos decenas
y una unidad tenemos
y un puntitos en un dado de seis lados